♪ ♪ ♪
- Hi! I have something to say!
- OK...
- Caroline Dhavernas, vous avez
vécu le rêve américain en jouant
dans des séries comme Wonderful,
The Pacific, Hannibal.
- What was done to you...
doesn't excuse what you did.
- À quoi il ressemble, le rêve
américain? Parce que vous avez
une grosse maison à Los Angeles,
un gros appart à New York. C'est
un peu comme ça que ça se passe?
(petit rire)
CAROLINE DHAVERNAS, actrice
- Moi, l'appartement que
j'avais à New York, c'était
vraiment une boîte à souliers,
comme on dit. C'était
un petit appartement qui
me servait de pied-à-terre
pendant toute ma vingtaine.
C'était extraordinaire d'avoir
cette chance-là dans un quartier
magnifique. Mais c'était loin
d'être... pour ceux qui l'ont
eu, il y a beaucoup de gens,
d'ailleurs, qui l'ont sous-loué.
À Montréal, des fois, il y a
des gens que je connais pas
qui viennent me voir pour
me dire qu'ils ont sous-loué
mon appartement. Et donc,
c'était pas... ouais, c'était
loin d'être une grosse cabane.
Moi, je suis une personne
très terre à terre, OK,
fait que juste l'expression
"rêve américain", elle me fait
un petit peu peur, parce que
je trouve qu'il y a beaucoup
de risques d'espoir brisé
là-dedans, puis de...
je sais pas, de... de rêver
à un truc qui ne peut pas,
dans le fond... en tout cas.
Donc moi, j'ai toujours suivi
ce que la vie m'offrait comme
chances, comme opportunités,
en travaillant très fort,
mais voilà, j'ai jamais eu
une espèce de rêve que
je caressais et de...
tant mieux si ça se passe
pour moi du côté des États-Unis,
mais j'ai jamais été sur
un cheval blanc à essayer
de conquérir quoi que ce soit.
Well, if I don't see you
before you go...
take care of yourself.
- Est-ce que c'est aussi
précieux que ça en a l'air?
- Bien, c'est un métier
extraordinaire, avec des moments
magnifiques. Mais il y a aussi
des moments difficiles, que ce
soit quand on travaille moins,
que ce soit quand on travaille
fort puis qu'il fait frette
puis que les textes arrivent
à la dernière minute, puis bon,
il y a plein de moments
comme ça où on se dit :
c'est pas très glamour,
finalement, mais il y a
les tapis rouges puis
les sorties des films et les...
quand on décroche une audition
et qu'on saute de joie, donc
c'est fait de hauts et de bas,
mais on ne sait jamais ce qui
s'en vient, donc il y a beaucoup
d'inquiétudes parfois, aussi.
- Vos deux parents
sont comédiens.
- Oui.
- J'imagine qu'ils vous
ont montré comment vivre
avec les hauts et les bas
d'une carrière.
- Je sais pas s'ils m'ont
montré comment faire,
mais je les ai vus faire.
- Oh!
(rires)
- Eh oui, j'ai vu les moments
où il y a moins de travail,
j'ai vu les moments où il y a
trop de travail, et donc...
Il y a une chose que j'essaie
de pas faire en ce moment,
vu que j'ai rien devant moi
justement, c'est de m'inquiéter
et de passer tout le temps
que j'ai justement à être
en congé à me demander si
je vais retravailler un jour,
parce qu'il y a tellement
de choses que je veux faire
en dehors de mon travail et
j'ai le temps de les faire en
ce moment. Et ce serait vraiment
triste, comme j'ai vu beaucoup
d'acteurs faire, de passer
toute cette période-là
à se dire : qu'est-ce qui
va se passer? Je suis stressée,
j'ai pas de travail, etc.
Et donc, moi, je viens d'avoir
un bébé, j'ai le temps de passer
de beaux moments avec elle,
alors j'essaie d'en profiter.
- Après toutes vos années
aux États-Unis, vous êtes
revenue au Québec. Pourquoi
vous avez fait ce choix-là?
- Ouais, des fois, Montréal,
quand j'étais partie longtemps,
me manquait terriblement,
ma culture, ma langue,
les ruelles de Montréal,
il y a rien de tel ailleurs.
Alors, oui, ça a toujours été
pour moi un heureux mélange
d'avoir le privilège de voyager
avec mon travail, mais aussi
de toujours revenir au bercail.
- Oui, mais vous vous faites
peut-être moins arrêter dans
la rue qu'aux États-Unis,
par contre?
- À Montréal?
- Oui.
- Non! Plus ici encore, parce
que les gens se souviennent de
mon travail quand j'étais ado,
dans Zap, des trucs comme ça,
t'sais. Ouais, vraiment.
Je veux vieillir comme toi.
- Ah!
- Tu as juste quelques petites
rides de rien. Pour le reste,
tu es pareille.
(rires)
- Encore aujourd'hui?
- Oui, oui! Ça arrive encore.
C'est rare, mais ça arrive.
Oui, j'ai quand même...
les gens connaissent plus
mon travail encore au Québec
que dans le reste du monde.
- Mais quand les gens
vous parlent de téléséries
que vous avez faites
il y a 25 ans... ish?
- Ouais?
- Ça vous étonne pas un peu?
- Bien... oui et non, parce que
moi, je me souviens des séries
que j'écoutais à cette époque-
là, donc... tant mieux
si les gens ont une mémoire
qui retient des chose qui
se passaient il y a 25 ans!
- Vous êtes une mordue de
télévision, une mordue de cinéma
aussi. Vous êtes sur le jury
du Festival du nouveau cinéma,
qui bat son plein. Et vous êtes
DJ, aussi, pour ce festival?
- oui, oui, oui.
- On ne vous connaissait pas
des talents de DJ.
- Moi non plus!
(rires)
- Vous non plus?
- Non! J'étais vraiment contente
et étonnée, à la fois, qu'on me
demande de faire ça. J'adore
la musique, j'adore danser et,
dans mes partys entre amis,
des fois, je fais le DJ.
Mais je l'ai jamais fait de
façon professionnelle, alors
j'étais très excitée qu'on me
demande ça. J'ai hâte...
j'espère être à la hauteur.
- Caroline Dhavernas,
merci beaucoup.
Ça été un plaisir, merci.
- Merci beaucoup! Merci.